authorities in myanmar have detained
britain's former ambassador to the
southeast asian nation where a military
junta seized power last year vikki
bowman who currently runs the myanmar
center for responsible business was
detained on wednesday along with her
husband and charged with immigration
offences her husband ten lin is one of
myanmar's most famous artists and a
veteran activist who was previously
imprisoned for his opposition to an
earlier junta let's speak to sky's
cordelia lynch who's in bangkok for us
this morning and cordelia what what do
we know about why exactly they've been
detained beyond these immigration
offences
well there has been no official
confirmation that in fact this arrest
has taken place we have put questions to
the military regime in yangon but we
have not heard back there's been no
information forthcoming we have heard
from the foreign office in a statement
in which a spokesperson said we are
concerned by the arrest of a british
woman in myanmar we are in contact with
the local authorities and are providing
consular assistance now uh as you
touched on she ran the center for
responsible business she was considered
pro-business a friend that we have
spoken to wanted to speak uh off the
record said that she was well known
within yangon that she had been there
for more than 20 years that she had
spoken
burmese now there is some local
reporting within burma that is suggested
that she and her husband were arrested
under an immigration
law uh with a possible sentence of some
time between six months
and five years and now as i say no
official confirmation but we have heard
from
a friend
um who one of our sources has spoken to
with inside yangon and now that friend
who didn't want to be identified says i
can confirm that she was arrested last
night i can confirm that the british
embassy senior officials and consular
staff have been working last night and
all day today on her case
vicky said
the source says that insane prison her
husband is with her an embassy staff
we have also spoken to an activist who
said that they knew vicky
and said that this is the shocking news
that
she considers herself neutral even
respected uh by the junta now
a kind of broader context of what's
taking place there at the moment there
are
diplomatic and economic tensions uh
within the country at the moment uh
there has been some conflict arising
over uk sanctions on those
businesses are backing
military
officials at this point but we just
don't know and can't be drawn on any
potential detail of the this arrest if
indeed it did take place or what it
might be connected to
um but of course we we know that the
military junta took power um a year ago
um after uh the overthrow of aung sang
tsuchi and we await more information
about vicki bowman